Hey everybody. Ira here. This episode of our show contains words that were beeped when we broadcast this over the radio that are not beeped in this online version.
大家好，我是艾拉。我们节目的这一集包含了一些在广播中被消音的词汇，但在网络版本中没有消音。
Leonetta Sanders, the principal of Harper High School in Chicago, has a decision to make. And she has to make it right away. She has to decide whether to cancel the school's homecoming game and dance.
芝加哥哈珀高中的校长莱昂内塔·桑德斯面临一个抉择。她必须立即做出决定。她得决定是否要取消学校的返校节球赛和舞会。
Coach Reed, I need you in the Melon room at this time, Coach Reed. Coach Sales.
里德教练，我现在需要你去甜瓜室，里德教练。塞勒斯教练。
She calls her staff together for a meeting. The day before this, when everybody was at a pep rally in the gym for Homecoming, a 16-year-old who attended Harper last year and dropped out, who still had friends here, was shot just a few blocks from school. Immediately, the staff jumped into action.
她召集教职员工开会。就在前一天，当大家都在体育馆参加返校节加油大会时，一名去年从哈珀退学、在这里还有朋友的16岁少年在离学校仅几个街区的地方被枪杀。教职员工立即采取了行动。
If you heard our radio program last week, you heard this part of the story, where it was the gang responsible for the shooting had members on the football team. So Principal Sanders was scared that there might be retaliation at the game or at the dance. They sent home a handful of kids they thought might be in danger.
如果你听了我们上周的广播节目，你就会听到故事的这一部分：实施枪击的帮派成员就在足球队里。所以桑德斯校长很担心球赛或舞会上会发生报复事件。他们让一小部分他们认为可能有危险的孩子回家了。
Here is what happens next. When the staff now assembles on Friday afternoon, Principal Sanders informs them that there's news. Another incident.
接下来发生的事情是这样的。当教职员工在周五下午聚集时，桑德斯校长通知他们有了新消息。又发生了一起事件。
OK, so I just got word that there was a shooting. But it was a shooting in the neighborhood. Anthony Harper's father picked him up. And by the time he crossed 67th, there were shooting. So it's starting already.
好的，我刚接到消息说又发生了枪击事件。但在社区里发生的。安东尼·哈珀的父亲去接他。等他穿过第67街时，那里发生了枪击。所以，一切已经开始了。
Nobody was hurt in this latest shooting. Though I think to any outsider, it's hard to imagine Harper not canceling Homecoming at this point. The school has just come off a terrible year in which 29 current and recent students were shot. Eight of them died. Dozens more were in incidents where bullets were fired, but they didn't get hit.
在这起最新的枪击事件中没有人受伤。虽然我想对任何局外人来说，很难想象哈珀在此时还不取消返校节。这所学校刚度过了糟糕的一年，有29名在校生和近期毕业生被枪击。其中8人死亡。还有数十人在子弹射出的事件中没有被击中。
These murders, as you would expect, were hard on faculty and students alike. But partly because it's been so tough, Principle Sanders wants very badly to give her students the fun, normal stuff that other high school students get, as much as she can. She really wants them to have a Homecoming dance. And so, her decision--
正如你所预料的，这些谋杀案对教职工和学生都造成了沉重打击。但正是因为这段日子太艰难了，桑德斯校长非常渴望能尽可能地给学生们提供其他高中生能享受到的那些有趣、正常的活动。她真心希望他们能举办一场返校节舞会。因此，她的决定是——
We are going to move forward with this dance. I have been on the phone, basically, all day with Tony Ruiz, Chicago police. So they're going to be standing on corners. Tony Ruiz says he's going to have some undercover police cars and rapid response.
我们要继续举办这场舞会。我基本上整天都在和芝加哥警方的托尼·鲁伊斯通电话。所以他们会站在街角。托尼·鲁伊斯说他会安排一些便衣警车和快速反应部队。
When school lets out at the end of the day, it's tense. There are more police cars than usual. Harper security staff and administrators are out on the sidewalks in force. Principal Sanders is wary as she looks up and down the street for any kids that seem out of place, who might be there for the wrong reasons.
放学时，气氛非常紧张。警车比平时多。哈珀的安保人员和管理人员全都出动站在人行道上。桑德斯校长警惕地看着街道两头，留意那些看起来格格不入、可能有不良动机的孩子。
I'll make sure I-- who is that? He don't go to Harper. Who is that?
我会确保我……那是谁？他不是哈珀的学生。那是谁？
I'll check. When I go back in, I'll check.
我去检查一下。等我回来时，我会确认。
You know, when they get cold, they start wearing these damn black hoodies. It's really pissing me off. Why he walking this way?
你知道，天冷的时候，他们就开始穿这些该死的黑色连帽衫。这真让我火大。他为什么那样走路？
Sanders talks to one of the police officers. He throws on his lights, drives down the block, questions the kid, puts him against the wall and checks for weapons, and then lets him go. And very soon, it's time for the game.
桑德斯和其中一名警察谈话。警察打开警灯，开车沿着街区行驶，盘问那个孩子，让他靠墙站好检查是否携带武器，然后放他走了。很快，球赛的时间到了。
Let's go Cardinals! Let's go! Let's go, Cardinals!
加油红雀队！加油！加油，红雀队！
There's no violence at the game, unless you count the incredible trouncing the Harper Cardinals give to Marshall High School.
球赛中没有发生暴力事件，除非你算上哈珀红雀队对马歇尔高中那场惊人的碾压性胜利。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
Final score, 40 to 0. Later, at the Homecoming dance, dressed up kids slowly stream through the metal detector.
最终比分40比0。后来在返校节舞会上，盛装打扮的孩子们缓慢地穿过金属探测器。
If you're not a Harper student, have your IDs out.
如果你不是哈珀的学生，请出示身份证件。
As for the dance, after all the worrying and the beefed-up security, what ended up happening is nothing-- the best possible outcome. The teenager who had been shot on Thursday, James Williams, made it to the hospital and survived. Maybe because of that, there was no other immediate bloodshed. Kids dance in a darkened gym. On the bleachers, you can make out Barielle, the Homecoming Queen, her dainty crown bouncing up and down at the center of this mass of kids.
至于舞会，在经历所有的担忧和加强安保之后，最终什么都没发生——这是最好的结果。周四被枪击的少年詹姆斯·威廉姆斯被送往医院后活了下来。也许正因为如此，没有发生其他即时的流血事件。孩子们在昏暗的体育馆里跳舞。在看台上，你可以看到返校节女王巴里埃尔，她精致的皇冠在这一大群孩子中间上下跳动。
For the staff, who have been here at this point for 14 hours, the significance of this moment is not lost. It's regular life. They were able to give the kids regular high school for a night-- a dance. Three girlfriends collect crumpled dollar bills together to make $10 bucks so they can pose, one in wobbly high heels, in front of the fake Roman columns and sky-blue backdrop the photographer's set up.
对于此时已经在学校待了14个小时的教职员工来说，这一刻的意义不言而喻。这是正常生活。他们能够让孩子们享受一个晚上的普通高中生活——一场舞会。三个女朋友凑齐了皱巴巴的美元钞票凑成10块钱，这样她们就可以在摄影师搭建的仿罗马柱和天蓝色背景前拍照，其中一个还穿着摇摇晃晃的高跟鞋。
On three-- one, two--
数到三——一，二——
That's him.
是他。
Three. There you go.
三。好了。
Today on our radio program, we spend a second hour at Harper High School on Chicago's South Side. We sent three reporters there for five months, starting at the beginning of this school year, because of all the shootings they've had. We have all heard a lot about gun violence and kids in the last few months. Here at our radio program, we wanted to understand what the staff and families at Harper know about this violence that most of us around the country do not know.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们将在芝加哥南区的哈珀高中度过第二个小时。我们派了三名记者在那里待了五个月，从本学年开始时算起，因为他们经历了太多的枪击事件。过去几个月，我们都听了很多关于枪支暴力和孩子们的事。在我们广播节目组，我们想了解哈珀的教职员工和家庭对这种暴力的了解，而这是我们全国大多数人所不知道的。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. You do not have to have heard our first hour on Harper High School to follow what happens in this second hour.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。你不需要听过我们关于哈珀高中的第一个小时节目，也能理解第二个小时发生的事情。
We're going to be focusing more on the students in this hour. We're going to get to know a few of their stories. Stay with us.
在这个小时里，我们将更多地关注学生。我们将去了解他们中的一些故事。请继续收听。
Act One, The Eyewitness. Most murders in Chicago-- 82% of them in 2011-- happen in public places, parks and streets and alleyways and cars. And lots of kids at Harper will tell you that they personally have actually seen someone shot. One of the three reporters we sent into the school, Alex Kotlowitz, has this story about a student who has seen more than his share.
第一幕，目击者。芝加哥的大多数谋杀案——2011年其中82%的案件——发生在公共场所，公园、街道、小巷和车里。哈珀的许多孩子会告诉你，他们亲眼见过有人被枪杀。我们派往学校的三名记者之一，亚历克斯·科特洛维茨，有这样一个关于一名见识过太多此类事件的学生的故事。
In the five months I spent at Harper, nearly every time I visited the school's social work office, which was often, Thomas, a junior, would be there, too, during classes, passing periods, lunch, whenever. So much that one day I asked him, hey, every time I come here, you're here. Why do you hang out here so much?
在我待在哈珀的五个月里，几乎每次我到学校的社会工作办公室（我经常去），托马斯（一名高二学生）也会在那里，上课期间、课间休息、午餐时，随时都在。以至于有一天我问他，嘿，每次我来这儿，你都在。你为什么这么喜欢在这儿待着？
Nay, I ain't gonna give you no answer for that. Every time I come here, you come. And I'm for real.
不，我才不会回答你。每次我来这儿，你都来。我是认真的。
No, every time I come, you're here.
不，每次我来，你都在。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Sometimes, I just need to talk to somebody. That's why I come here.
有时候，我只是需要和某人聊聊。所以我才来这儿。
Thomas has witnessed an incredible amount of violence. Last June, he was standing on the porch of an abandoned building, talking with another Harper student, Shakaki Asphy, when she was shot and killed. This, though, wasn't the first murder Thomas had witnessed.
托马斯目睹了惊人的暴力事件。去年六月，他站在一栋废弃建筑的门廊上，和另一名哈珀学生沙卡基·阿斯菲聊天时，她被枪杀身亡。但这并不是托马斯目睹的第一起谋杀案。
Back in 2006, he was at a birthday party for 10-year-old girl, Siretha White, nicknamed Nugget, when someone shot though the front window. Thomas says he remembers being led out of the house by the police and seeing Nugget laying on the floor with what appeared to be her brains next to her. Nugget's killing happened when Thomas was 10. Shakaki's murder was when Thomas was 17. And as his social worker, Anita Stewart, tells it, there have been many, many in between.
早在2006年，他在参加10岁女孩西雷莎·怀特（绰号“小块”）的生日派对时，有人从前窗开枪。托马斯说他记得自己被警察带出屋子，看到“小块”躺在地板上，旁边好像是她的脑浆。西雷莎遇害时托马斯10岁。沙卡基遇害时托马斯17岁。正如他的社会工作者安妮塔·斯图尔特所说，这期间还发生过很多很多次。
Last summer, one of the kids in the neighborhood got shot in the face. He witnessed that. Then it was a student here that got shot in the leg. He was a witness to that.
去年夏天，社区里的一个孩子脸部中弹。他目睹了那一幕。后来这儿的一个学生腿部中弹。他目睹了那一幕。
And there was some guy-- and I don't know. He never really fully told me about this story. But he got shot in the head. And he was talking about his brains being on the ground. So he witnessed that.
还有一个家伙——我不知道。他从没完全告诉我这个故事。但他头部中弹了。他谈到他的脑浆洒在地上。所以他目睹了那一幕。
Thomas's brother has been shot on three separate occasions. Thomas witnessed all of them, including the time his brother was paralyzed.
托马斯的兄弟曾三次中弹。托马斯目睹了所有这些，包括他兄弟瘫痪的那一次。
Good morning, Thomas.
早上好，托马斯。
Good morning.
早上好。
And I can understand why you didn't get here on time this morning. You know that your sister says that she wakes you up every morning.
我能理解你为什么今天早上没准时到。你知道你姐姐说她每天早上都会叫你起床的。
My mama just brought me here.
是我妈刚把我送来的。
Lower your voice. I'm right here. It's so good to see you this morning.
小声点。我就在这儿。今天早上见到你真好。
Why you just come talking about--
你为什么刚过来就谈论——
Thomas and Anita have an interesting relationship. He's pretty combative, kind of churlish. At times, it almost seems like he doesn't even like Anita very much. But the truth is they're incredibly close.
托马斯和安妮塔有一种有趣的关系。他相当好斗，有点粗鲁。有时，看起来他甚至不太喜欢安妮塔。但事实是他们非常亲近。
Anita splits her time between Harper and another high school. And the two or three days a week she's at Harper, Thomas always comes to see her. She frequently visits him on his block and at his house, and affectionately calls him big baby. I don't think Thomas opens up much to many people, but he does with Anita.
安妮塔将她的时间分配在哈珀和另一所高中之间。她每周有两三天在哈珀，托马斯总是来看她。她经常去他的街区和家里看望他，并亲切地称他为“大宝宝”。我不认为托马斯会对很多人敞开心扉，但他对安妮塔会。
You know Nugget's little brother got shot Monday.
你知道“小块”的弟弟周一被枪击了吗？
No. Is he OK?
不知道。他没事吧？
He go shot in his stomach and his leg.
他肚子和腿上中弹了。
Her little brother? How old is her little brother?
她的弟弟？她弟弟多大？
Like 15.
大概15岁吧。
And what school does he go to?
他在哪个学校上学？
I don't know.
我不知道。
So what did you think about it when you heard about it, after you heard about it?
那么当你听说这件事之后，你是怎么想的？
Nothing.
没怎么想。
Nothing?
没怎么想？
Just another person got shot.
只是又有一个人被枪杀了。
Just another person got shot? [SIGH]
只是又有一个人被枪杀了？[叹气]
You can hear it in Thomas's voice, muffled and sluggish, as if he's speaking from deep inside a cave. Even his physical demeanour makes it clear he'd just as well disappear.
你能从托马斯的声音里听出来，低沉而迟缓，仿佛他是在一个深深的洞穴里说话。甚至他的身体姿态也清楚地表明他宁愿消失。
His braided hair hangs over his eyes. He often has a hood on. He won't look you in the eye. Anita's trying to pull him out of his hiding.
他编织的头发遮住了眼睛。他经常戴着兜帽。他不看你的眼睛。安妮塔正试图把他从隐藏中拉出来。
Hey, Thomas. What did you think of the memorial for Shakaki?
嘿，托马斯。你觉得沙卡基的纪念活动怎么样？
I walked past it. I don't know.
我走过那里。我不知道。
Have you looked at it?
你去看过吗？
At the end of October, on the first floor, the school put up a memorial display for Shakaki, the girl Thomas was standing next to when she was killed. It's a glass case filled with pictures of her and her friends, a basketball signed by her teammates, and a note Anita had written to her after she died. Shakaki, who, like so many kids at Harper, half expect to die young, had told Anita if she was killed, she wanted her to put a note in her casket. After she was killed, Anita wrote the note, but you couldn't bring herself to put it in which Shakaki.
十月底，在二楼，学校为沙卡基设立了一个纪念展览，就是托马斯被杀时站在旁边的那个女孩。那是一个玻璃柜，里面装满了她和朋友们的照片、队友签名的篮球，还有安妮塔在她死后写给她的纸条。沙卡基和哈珀的许多孩子一样，半预料到自己会早逝，曾告诉安妮塔，如果她被杀，她希望她把一张纸条放在她的棺材里。在她被杀后，安妮塔写了这张纸条，但她无法让自己把它放进棺材里。
Anita had worked with Shakaki for two years. And she's still struggling with their own grief over her death. And partly, it's the shared grief that draws Anita and Thomas together. Like Thomas, Anita hasn't been able to bring herself to look at the memorial.
安妮塔和沙卡基一起工作了两年。她仍在努力克服自己对她离世的悲痛。在某种程度上，是这种共同的悲伤将安妮塔和托马斯联系在一起。像托马斯一样，安妮塔一直无法让自己去看那个纪念台。
Because I haven't looked at it. I saw it. But I could not go up there. I'm not ready to go up there yet. So why haven't you gone up there to look at it?
因为我没去看过。我看到了。但我没法走过去。我还没准备好走过去。那你为什么没去看看呢？
I don't need to go up there right now.
我现在不需要去那里。
OK. I do have a question for you, Thomas. With all of the things that you have experienced, which one is constantly on your mind? You've experienced so much.
好的。托马斯，我有个问题。经历了这么多事情，哪一件一直萦绕在你的脑海里？你经历过太多了。
I don't think about none of that.
我什么都不去想。
You don't think about none of it? None of it's on your mind. Not the situation with your brother? What about at the bus stop? What about at the party?
你什么都不去想？没有一件事情在你的脑海里吗？你兄弟的情况呢？巴士站那边呢？派对那边呢？
No, I don't think about that.
没有，我不去想那些。
You don't think about the party when you were a kid?
你不去想小时候参加的那个派对吗？
Man, I got older. That stuff is old now.
老兄，我已经长大了。那些事已经是过去式了。
It's old? You remember what happened, right?
是过去式？你还记得发生了什么，对吧？
Right, but--
对，但是——
Does it really get old, Thomas?
那真的会成为过去式吗，托马斯？
It's done now.
现在已经结束了。
It's done. I know and I understand that it's done. But does it really get old, where you can say, OK, this is over, I don't think about it anymore?
结束了。我知道，我理解它结束了。但这真的能成为过去式，让你说，“好吧，事情结束了，我不再想它了”吗？
But if I think about it, I'll do something.
但如果我想到它，我会做出点什么。
You'll do something like what?
你会做出什么？
Try to hurt somebody.
试图伤害某人。
Try to hurt somebody, he says. Trying to hurt someone or wanting to hurt someone, these are things Thomas has said a lot. One time when I asked him where he thought he might be in 10 years, he said, might be in jail, because I think I'm going to hurt someone.
“试图伤害某人”，他说。试图伤害某人或者想伤害某人，这些是托马斯常说的话。有一次我问他十年后觉得自己会在哪儿，他说，可能会在监狱里，因为我觉得我会伤害某人。
Mostly it felt like tough talk, like teenage bravado. But on this day, when talking about Shakaki, it started to become clear that this kind of talk, talk about hurting someone, isn't just tough guy bragging. I began to realize that Thomas was trying the best he could to be honest about some feelings he has, feelings that scare him. Thomas begins by haltingly explaining what happened the night Shakaki was shot.
大部分时候听起来像是硬话，像少年的虚张声势。但就在这一天，当谈到沙卡基时，开始变得清楚，这种谈话，关于伤害某人的谈话，不仅仅是硬汉的吹嘘。我开始意识到托马斯正在尽其所能坦诚地表达他的一些感受，这些让他感到害怕的感受。托马斯开始断断续续地解释沙卡基被枪杀的那天晚上发生了什么。
He was standing on the porch, Shakaki next to him. They were just hanging out, just talking. Thomas's brother was in his wheelchair on the sidewalk in front.
他站在门廊上，沙卡基就在他旁边。他们只是待在那里，随便聊聊。托马斯的兄弟坐在人行道上的轮椅里。
When the shooter, dressed in a gray hoodie, came running up alongside the building, Thomas pleaded with him not to shoot. But the shooter fired several rounds, hitting Shakaki three times and Thomas's brother once in the thigh. Thomas ran but quickly came back. He says that when Shakaki was laying on the ground, he first thought she'd be OK.
当那个穿着灰色兜帽的枪手跑到大楼旁边时，托马斯恳求他不要开枪。但枪手连开了几枪，击中沙卡基三次，击中托马斯兄弟大腿一次。托马斯跑了，但很快又回来了。他说，当沙卡基躺在地上时，他最初以为她会没事的。
Because when she got shot, then anyways, she gonna be all right then.
因为当她中弹时，总之，她那时会没事的。
She was talking, right?
她在说话，对吧？
She was on the  ground. She was talking. But all she kept saying, it burned.
她躺在地上。她在说话。但她一直在说，好烫。
She was saying that it burned. When the ambulances finally showed up, they took Shakaki and Thomas's brother to the hospital, leaving Thomas alone. He didn't go home. He was just alone.
她在说好烫。当救护车最终赶到时，他们把沙卡基和托马斯的兄弟带走了，只留下托马斯一个人。他没回家。他只是一个人。
Then they took her. Then they took my brother. Then I walked off mad. I walked to the gas station to see who I could see.
然后他们带走了她。然后带走了我兄弟。然后我愤怒地走开了。我走到加油站看看能不能碰到谁。
At the gas station, he didn't find anyone.
在加油站，他没碰到任何人。
And ever since that day, I was just trying to hurt everybody. I didn't sleep that whole week she got killed. She got shot on Saturday. She died Sunday. I was sleepless for a whole week.
从那天起，我就一直在试图伤害每个人。她被杀的那整周我都没睡。她是周六被枪杀的。她周日去世了。我整整一周失眠。
He was filled with grief, anxiety, guilt. And then he got into a fight.
他充满了悲伤、焦虑、内疚。然后他打了一架。
And what did you get into a fight over?
你是因为什么打架的？
Nothing important.
没啥重要的。
Thomas says an older kid on the street pushed his little cousin to the ground. Thomas was furious. He went after the older boy.
托马斯说街上的一个大孩子把他的小表弟推倒在地上。托马斯火冒三丈。他去追那个大男孩。
It wasn't no fight. I just hit him. And he walked off crying a whole lot. I didn't know his teeth was in my hand until I looked at it.
那不是打架。我只是打了他。他哭着跑开了。直到我看着自己的手，我才知道他的牙齿卡在我手里了。
Thomas punched the boy so hard, one of the boy's teeth got stuck in Thomas hand. Later that night, his grandma took him to the hospital. And he eventually had surgery on his hand.
托马斯重重地打了那个男孩，那个男孩的一颗牙齿卡在了托马斯的手里。那天晚上晚些时候，他奶奶带他去了医院。他最终对手进行了手术。
He told me that once he hurt his hand, he was able to sleep again. It was that simple. Getting into this stupid fight, it brought him relief.
他告诉我，一旦他的手受伤，他又能入睡了。就这么简单。打这场无聊的架给他带来了宽慰。
Thomas has said many times that he knows something violent is going to happen again. It could be random. He says bullets fly all the time.
托马斯多次说过，他知道暴力事件还会发生。它可能是随机的。他说子弹随时在飞。
One could come through the living room window and hit his grandma. Or a stray bullet could hit Anita when she's on the block. What happens happens, he often says. And when it happens next, he knows he'll need relief again.
一颗子弹可能会穿过客厅窗户击中他奶奶。或者一颗流弹可能会击中街区的安妮塔。发生的就是发生了，他经常这么说。当下次发生时，他知道他再次需要宽慰。
If it happens again, I don't think I could stop.
如果它再次发生，我不认为我能停下来。
You're worried that will be the breaking point for you?
你担心那是你的崩溃点吗？
No, I ain't worried about nothing. If it happens again, though, I know I could hurt a lot of people if I wanted to.
不，我什么都不担心。不过如果它再次发生，我知道如果我想的话，我可以伤害很多人。
I don't think you want to. I really don't think you want to.
我不认为你想。我真的认为你不想。
Anita's trying to convince Thomas to deal with his feelings in other ways. Not long ago, they visited Shakaki's gravesite together. Anita says is was big deal for Thomas to go. I'm proud of him, she told me.
安妮塔正试图说服托马斯用其他方式处理他的情绪。不久前，他们一起去了沙卡基的墓地。安妮塔说托马斯能去是一个很大的突破。我为他感到骄傲，她告诉我。
Alex Kotlowitz, he'll be back later in our hour.
亚历克斯·科特洛维茨，他稍后会在我们节目中回来。
Act Two, Your Name Written On Us. In the unofficial school calendar for Harper, there are these anniversaries of days that certain kids were shot or the birthdays of those same kids. They have a big enough effect on what happens at school  that the administration and the police department keep track of these days. They can be dangerous.
第二幕，你的名字刻在我们身上。在哈珀非官方的学校校历里，有一些特定的孩子被枪击的日子或同样那些孩子的生日纪念日。它们对学校发生的事情有足够大的影响，以至于管理层和警察局会追踪这些日子。它们可能是危险的。
One of the important anniversaries in the fall is TG day, named for Terrance Green. In all kinds of ways since his death at 16, Terrance Green has become one of the iconic figures in the neighborhood around Harper. Ben Calhoun looked into how that happened.
秋季重要的周年纪念日之一是“TG日”，以特伦斯·格林命名。自他16岁去世以来，特伦斯·格林以各种方式成为了哈珀周围社区的标志性人物之一。本·卡尔霍恩调查了这是如何发生的。
Terrance Green was murdered during summer break, July, 2009. But more than a month later, when kids came back to school, the grief over his death. It was still flooding from the neighborhood into Harper.
特伦斯·格林在2009年7月暑假期间被谋杀。但在那一个多月后，当孩子们回到学校时，对他的死感到悲痛。那种情绪依然从社区涌入哈珀。
It was the largest fallout of a student death I had ever seen before. Even the boys couldn't hold back their tears.
这是我见过的学生死亡事件中影响最大的一次。连男孩们都无法抑制住眼泪。
Crystal Smith, one of the school's social workers. In some ways, she says that wasn't so surprising. Terrance was popular and charming and funny. But she was still not expecting what she saw next.
克里斯托·史密斯，学校的社会工作者之一。在某些方面，她说这并不令人惊讶。特伦斯受欢迎、迷人且风趣。但她仍然没想到接下来会看到什么。
I started seeing this TGC, TGC, TGC everywhere. Whether it be I was seeing it on book bags or tattooed on one of the kids. And I was like, what is that? And they were like, oh, you know, this is the Terrance Green Crew. It turned into a whole different gang.
我开始到处看到“TGC”、“TGC”、“TGC”。不管是在书包上还是纹在孩子们的身上。我就想，那是什么？他们说，哦，你知道，这是“特伦斯·格林帮”。它变成了一个完全不同的帮派。
The new clique, the new gang that Terrance's death gave birth to, today it controls 23 city blocks in the neighborhood east of Harper. It's called Terrance Green City, goes by the initials TGC. Sometimes it's called True Gangster City.
特伦斯的死催生的这个新团体、新帮派，今天控制着哈珀东边社区的23个街区。它被称为“特伦斯·格林城”，缩写为TGC。有时它也被称为“真正的流氓城”。
For TGC and two or three other allied gangs, the dates of Terrance's death and his birthday in November, in the neighborhood, those days are a big deal. Hundreds of people turn out for street parties. And around those times, the hostility over Terrance's murder, it can all come back. Crystal remembers last November. The staff was told to clear out of the building immediately when school ended.
对于TGC和其他两三个盟友帮派来说，特伦斯的忌日和11月的生日，在社区里，这些日子非常重要。成百上千的人会参加街头派对。而在这些日子前后，因特伦斯谋杀案引发的敌意，可能会卷土重来。克里斯托记得去年11月。学校刚结束，教职员工就被告知立即离开大楼。
And they had called in for extra police support. Somebody told me, they were like, they brought the big guns out.
他们还召集了额外的警察支援。有人告诉我，他们就像是说，他们把重型武器搬出来了。
Assault rifles. Some of the police outside the school were carrying assault rifles.
突击步枪。学校外的一些警察带着突击步枪。
But then as I was driving down the street, it was just like a scene I had never seen. I had never seen so many kids posted on the corners at one time. And I had never seen them standing outside with bats and sticks and stuff. And they were, like, on every street.
但当我开车沿着街道走时，那是我从未见过的场景。我从来没见过这么多孩子同时驻守在街角。我从来没见过他们站在外面拿着棒球棍、棍棒之类的东西。他们就像是在每一条街上。
Three years after Terrance Green's murder, the legacy left by it continues to sprawl. The song you're hearing is just one of the many tributes to Terrance online. There's also slide shows, collages, videos, some with slick editing and production. Lots are on YouTube.
在特伦斯·格林被谋杀三年后，他留下的遗产继续蔓延。你听到的这首歌只是网上众多纪念特伦斯的歌曲之一。还有幻灯片、拼贴画、视频，有些剪辑和制作都很娴熟。很多在YouTube上。
(SINGING) Yeah, TGC, you already know, man. Young Life, Seven Deuce man. RIP my nigga, man. Prince TG, Prince mother fucka TG. Yeah, we gonna miss you.
(歌声) 是的，TGC，你懂的，伙计。年轻的生活，七二号，伙计。安息吧，我的兄弟。TG王子，TG王子，他妈的。是的，我们会想念你的。
I got you tatted on my arm, man. The grief's still sitting on us, so we got your name written on us. You know how that go.
我把你纹在我的手臂上了，伙计。悲伤依然笼罩着我们，所以我们将你的名字刻在我们身上。你知道它是怎么回事。
The mythology around Terrance and the devotion to him, it's intense. Kids who know Terrance use his last name, Green, in place of their own. This was confusing at first, when I met several of his friends who told me their last name was Green. But the most troubling example of Terrance's legacy was this series of videos made by kids.
围绕特伦斯的神话和对他的奉献非常强烈。认识特伦斯的各种孩子用他的姓氏“格林”来代替自己的。起初这很令人困惑，当我遇到几个告诉我说他们姓格林的朋友时。但特伦斯遗产中最令人不安的例子是孩子们制作的这一系列视频。
The footage is choppy and grainy, like it's shot on a cell phone. It's of about a dozen kids walking around the street at night. They range in age from maybe 9 or 10 to early high school. Here, they are threatening and taunting a rival gang, S-Dub, which is also called the Dub. It's the gang that's widely believed by students, Harper staff, and police to have killed Terrance.
画面断断续续且粗糙，像是用手机拍的。大约有十几个人在晚上走在街上。他们的年龄从9或10岁到高中初期不等。在这里，他们威胁并嘲弄一个敌对帮派，S-Dub，也被称为“Dub”。这被学生、哈珀教职员工和警察普遍认为杀害了特伦斯。
For the rest of my life, I'm screaming, fuck the Dub!
在我的余生里，我大声疾呼，去死吧Dub！
Fuck the Dub!
去死吧Dub！
Toward the end of the video, one particular kid appears. He looks like he's barely out of middle school, somewhere between 12 and 14. In his right hand is a gun, a semi-automatic.
在视频快结束时，出现了特别的一个孩子。他看起来几乎还没出中学，在12到14岁之间。他右手拿着一把枪，一把半自动手枪。
He points it at the camera. He shouts hate at opposing gangs. He praises the territory he says he's protecting, Terrance Green City.
他指着镜头。他对着敌对帮派大声喊着仇恨。他称赞他所说的正在保护的领土——特伦斯·格林城。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉的声音]
The feud between TGC and S-Dub that followed Terrance's death, it's turned into a long chain of retaliation. Principle Sanders says her staff knows of seven murders and more than 10 other shootings that lead back to Terrance. This list includes Cedric Bell, one of Harper's students killed last year.
特伦斯死后TGC和S-Dub之间的仇恨，变成了一连串的报复行动。桑德斯校长说她的教职员工知道七起谋杀案和十多起枪击事件追溯到特伦斯身上。这个名单包括去年被杀的哈珀学生之一塞德里克·贝尔。
And it's not like Terrance's story is one of a kind. There's other cliques around Harper named after kids who were murdered. There's Bird gang northwest of the school named after Martel Barrett, whose nickname was Bird. He was killed the same year as Terrance. There's Face World, named for a kid whose street name was Face. There's Frank World and Dome City.
而且特伦斯的故事并不是个例。哈珀周围还有其他以被谋杀的孩子命名的帮派。学校西北部有一个“鸟帮”，是以马特尔·巴雷特命名的，他的绰号叫“鸟”。他和特伦斯同一年被杀。还有“脸面世界”，以一个绰号叫“脸面”的孩子命名。还有“弗兰克世界”和“圆顶城”。
It makes you wonder about the lives of these kids, kids like Terrance. Why did his death lead to songs and kids using his last name in place of their own to assault rifles outside Harper and a remapping of the violence around the school? Why this 16-year-old?
这让你不禁对这些孩子的生活产生疑问，像特伦斯那样的孩子。为什么他的死会导致歌曲、孩子们用他的姓氏代替自己的姓氏、哈珀校外的突击步枪以及学校周围暴力事件的重新划分？为什么是这个16岁的少年？
This is an eighth grade graduation picture.
这是他八年级的毕业照片。
What a cute kid.
多可爱的孩子。
Terrance grew up in a house with two loving, hardworking parents. This is his dad here, Tony Owens. He's a full-time bus driver and a union official for the Chicago Transit Authority. His mother, Lorraine Green, works at a bank. Together, the couple raised five kids.
特伦斯在一个有两位充满爱心、勤劳的父母的家庭中长大。这是他的父亲，托尼·欧文斯。他是一名全职巴士司机，也是芝加哥交通管理局的工会官员。他的母亲，洛林·格林，在银行工作。这对夫妇总共养育了五个孩子。
Terrance's siblings, at this point, have all graduated from high school. One's in college. The rest are all doing well. His older brother is a pastor.
此时，特伦斯的兄弟姐妹都已高中毕业。有一个在上大学。其余的都发展得很好。他的哥哥是一名牧师。
Hey, hey, here's my man, Boogie here.
嘿，嘿，这是我的兄弟，布吉。
How are you doing?
你好吗？
It's nice to meet you.
很高兴见到你。
He's here. Hey man, what's up [INAUDIBLE]?
他在这儿。嘿伙计，怎么了[听不清]？
A friend of Terrance's dropped by during one of my visits to Mr. Owens. Boogie was one of the closest people to Terrance. They were friends since third grade. As you're going to hear, there are some big differences in the way they see Terrance's story.
在一次我拜访欧文斯先生时，特伦斯的一个朋友顺道过来。布吉是特伦斯最亲近的人之一。他们从三年级起就是朋友。正如你即将听到的，他们在看待特伦斯故事的方式上存在一些重大分歧。
But here's the stuff they agree on. Terrance was an amazing athlete and a leader. When he was in middle school, he played quarterback for a youth league team that went to a national championship.
但这是他们一致认同的事。特伦斯是一位了不起的运动员和领袖。当他上中学时，他为一支进入全国锦标赛的青年联盟球队担任四分卫。
And they both say the problem started when Terrance was in high school. He and Boogie had to walk to Harper through a rival neighborhood. The kids there would bully Terrance and his friends. And then Terrance, he had a teenage fling with and then dumped the little sister of a gang member from the other neighborhood, from S-Dub, the gang that people believe killed him later.
他们俩都说问题始于特伦斯上高中时。他和布吉不得不穿过一个敌对的街区去哈珀。那里的孩子会欺负特伦斯和他的朋友。然后特伦斯，他和一个来自另一个街区、来自S-Dub（人们相信后来杀害他的那个帮派）的帮派成员的妹妹有过一段少年恋情，然后甩了她。
And she told him that my brother going to get you. She told Terrance that. My brother is going to get you. My brother gonna get you, because he wasn't dating her.
她告诉他，我哥哥会来收拾你的。她告诉特伦斯。我哥哥会来收拾你的。我哥哥会来收拾你，因为他当时没在和她交往。
The way Mr. Owens describes the situation, it was half girl problem, half bully problem. There were some fights in school, some fights on the street. And one Friday afternoon, Terrance got shot in a drive-by. Police reports show the brother was brought in for questioning but was not charged. No one was ever charged.
欧文斯先生描述情况的方式是，一半是女孩问题，一半是欺凌问题。学校里打过架，街上也打过架。一个周五下午，特伦斯在一次驾车枪击中中弹。警方报告显示哥哥被带走询问，但未被指控。没有人被指控。
And this is where Boogie's version of the story separates from Mr. Owens's on a crucial point. Mr. Owens says Terrance and Boogie and their friend's weren't in a gang. Boogie says that was true, but only at first.
而这就是布吉的故事版本在关键点上与欧文斯先生分道扬镳的地方。欧文斯先生说特伦斯和布吉还有他们的朋友不是帮派成员。布吉说那是真的，但仅限于起初。
Boogie tells the story this way. When it all started, there was the gang that the girl's brother was in, S-Dub. They were fighting with the older guys in Terrance's neighborhood who were in a gang called Seven Deuce. Boogie has no idea what that war was about-- girls, money, who knows? They'd been at it for years, he says.
布吉这样讲述故事。这一切开始时，有一个女孩哥哥所在的帮派，S-Dub。他们一直在和特伦斯街区里的一帮叫“七二号”的老家伙们打架。布吉不知道那场战争是因为什么——女孩、钱，谁知道呢？他说他们已经打了好几年了。
He and Terrance and their friends, they were separate from all that. They were just kids. They were interested in sports and music. They could cross into S-Dub's territory.
他和特伦斯以及他们的朋友，他们与所有这些隔离开来。他们只是孩子。他们对体育和音乐感兴趣。他们可以进入S-Dub的领地。
They'd go over, hang out, play basketball. It was no big deal. But by the time they got to high school, it was like a switch flipped on them.
他们过去，闲逛，打篮球。没什么大不了的。但当他们上高中时，就像是有人触动了开关。
Once they come through, and we taller now. It's all about height and stuff like that. So they call it hard legs, shooting at any hard legs. That means male-- any male that look of age.
一旦他们穿过，我们现在长高了。一切都是关于身高之类的事情。所以他们称之为“硬腿”，向任何“硬腿”开枪。那意味着男性——任何看起来成年了的男性。
Any male that look of age will get shot. So that's where it started, right there. You involved now. That's the thing. Now you a part of it.
任何看起来成年的男性都会中弹。所以这就是问题的起点。你现在卷进去了。这就是事情。你现在是它的一部分了。
Boogie says the guys from S-Dub, they just assumed they were with Seven Deuce because they were young men living in the neighborhood. So S-Dub would drive up, point guns at them, threaten them. They'd steal from them and take their stuff, embarrass them in front of girls. It was humiliating.
布吉说S-Dub的家伙们，他们只是假设他们和“七二号”是一伙的，因为他们是住在那个社区的年轻男性。所以S-Dub会开车过来，用枪指着他们，威胁他们。他们会抢劫他们，拿走他们的东西，在女孩面前羞辱他们。这很屈辱。
And avoiding all that didn't seem like an option. Police or parents or teachers weren't about to step in and fix it. So they turned to each other. They did what a lot of teenage boys might do in that situation. They decided they weren't going to back down.
而避开这一切似乎不是一个选择。警察、父母或老师不会介入来解决它。所以他们转向彼此。他们做了很多少年在那种情况下会做的事。他们决定不会退缩。
One member of TGC tells me Terrance got his friends together for a meeting. He said he was starting something new, a new group. He named it Yung Lyfe, which stood for young, unique, noble gentlemen living youthful and fulfilled every day.
TGC的一名成员告诉我特伦斯召集他的朋友们开会。他说他要开始做点新鲜事，一个新群体。他命名为“Yung Lyfe”，代表年轻、独特、高贵、绅士，生活青春且充实每一天。
Fear drove us to really get into it. We felt like we had to fight fire with fire. Like Terrance, he always was a stronger leader because he was the quarterback of a football team. So he knew how to lead a team. So we thought if they want to come burn us down, we gonna come burn they town down, too.
恐惧驱使我们真正参与其中。我们觉得必须以牙还牙。像特伦斯，他总是更强大的领袖，因为他是橄榄球队的四分卫。所以他知道如何领导团队。所以如果我们认为如果他们想来烧毁我们，我们也去烧毁他们的城镇。
All this was news to Mr. Owens, Terrance's dad. He never knew that Terrance and his friends were fighting back this way. And when he hears "fight fire with fire," the implication of that, it isn't something Mr. Owens is really ready to accept.
所有这一切对欧文斯先生（特伦斯的爸爸）来说都是新闻。他从不知道特伦斯和他的朋友们是以这种方式反击的。当他听到“以牙还牙”时，那其中的内涵，并不是欧文斯先生真正准备接受的。
You know, let me cut in just for a minute. When he say they retaliated off of that, I mean, what can they do? They didn't have no guns. I don't see how y'all could retaliate when you all didn't have what they had.
你知道，让我打断一下。当他说他们反击时，我的意思是，他们能做什么？他们根本没枪。我不明白当你们没他们有的东西时，怎么去反击。
They had more power than us. But we had more heart. Terrance had a big heart.
他们的力量比我们大。但我们有更多心。特伦斯有一颗宽大的心。
You can hear how delicate and respectful Boogie's trying to be with his friend's dad. But Mr. Owens insists, you didn't have any guns. And finally, Boogie admits it pretty plainly.
你能听到布吉试图对他朋友的父亲表现得多么细腻和尊重。但欧文斯先生坚持说，你们没枪。最后，布吉直白地承认了。
Yeah, they had things like guns and all type of weapons. But we had the same. We just didn't have as much as them. They had cars and all type of stuff. We were still using CTA.
是的，他们有枪和各种武器。但我们也有。我们只是没他们那么多。他们有车和各种各样的东西。我们还是用交通管理局的巴士。
It was crazy. But when they got back and forth, when the war really started, if they came on our side, they would have to worry about making it back to their side. And it was the same way for us.
这很疯狂。但当他们来来回回时，当战争真正开始时，如果他们来到我们这边，他们就得担心能不能回到他们那边。这对我们来说也是一样的。
Other friends of Terrance's have told me, by the summer when he was killed, the shooting was pretty much constant. One said, "I'm not going to lie. We were shooting pretty much every day. It was wolf season," he said.
特伦斯的其他朋友告诉我，在他被杀的那个夏天，枪击几乎是不断的。一个人说，“我不撒谎。我们几乎每天都在开枪。那是狼的季节，”他说。
When they talk about what all this was like, you can totally see why they memorialize Terrance the way they do-- because there'd been this moment when they felt scared and unprotected. He was the one that rallied them. He was their leader. And because he was their leader, he became a target. "He died for us," Boogie told me.
当他们谈论这一切是什么样子时，你可以完全看出他们为什么以这种方式纪念特伦斯——因为有过这样一个时刻，他们感到恐惧和不被保护。他是那个把他们团结起来的人。他是他们的领袖。因为他是他们的领袖，他成为了目标。“他为我们而死，”布吉告诉我。
You can see why they'd want to name their neighborhood after him. Boogie says part of what made those years so frightening for them is that they were underdogs. They were younger, smaller. And they had to figure out for themselves how to fight back. The older guys, the ones in Seven Deuce who'd started the war, they hadn't recruited them. They hadn't taught them how it all worked.
你可以看出他们为什么想用他的名字命名他们的街区。布吉说，那几年让他们感到恐惧的部分原因是他们是失败者。他们更年轻、更小。他们不得不自己弄清楚如何反击。那些老家伙们，那些在“七二号”里挑起战争的人，并没有招募他们。没教过他们这一切是如何运作的。
I'm not blaming it on nobody. But the older guys on our side, they kind of set us up for failure because they let the pressure fall on us. They didn't give nothing to us. But they let the weight fall off onto us. Now it's off of them. All the weight is off of them.
我没责怪任何人。但我们这边的老家伙们，他们有点让我们走向失败，因为他们把压力丢给了我们。他们没给我们任何东西。但他们把重担抛给了我们。现在重担从他们身上卸下了。所有的重担都从他们身上卸下了。
But now it's our problem. Their problems are our problems now. The weight was put on our shoulders and just dumped.
但现在这是我们的问题。他们的问题现在是我们的问题。重担压在我们的肩膀上，直接被抛弃了。
Like the older guys, they so separated from us. It's so segregated that we don't even know their names. But they the ones who started the war which led to Terrance getting killed. But I couldn't even recall one of their names if I wanted to.
就像那些老家伙们，他们和我们隔离开来。隔离得如此严重，以至于我们甚至不知道他们的名字。但他们是挑起导致特伦斯被杀战争的人。但我即使想回想也记不住他们的一个名字。
Of course, to an adult, this is upside down world logic, that the one thing that could have helped them and maybe saved Terrance's life was being recruited and trained by a gang, that the only adults who could have helped them were gang members. And the more Boogie said stuff like this, how they inherited this war, the more upset Mr. Owens got.
当然，对于成年人来说，这是颠倒的世界逻辑，即唯一能帮助他们并可能挽救特伦斯生命的事情就是被帮派招募和训练，即唯一能帮助他们的成年人是帮派成员。布吉说的这种话越多，关于他们如何继承了这场战争，欧文斯先生就越心烦。
Don't say you was inheriting nothing, because you wasn't. Inheriting means somebody gave you something. And nobody gave you nothing.
别说你们继承了什么，因为你们没有。继承意味着有人给了你什么。没人给你们任何东西。
And that's what I was saying.
这正是我要说的。
I'm saying you didn't have nothing to do with what was going on. Y'all was just kids is in hood. Y'all didn't know nothing about these guys. And I never heard this before.
我的意思是你和正在发生的事情毫无关系。你们只是街区里的孩子。你们对这些家伙一无所知。我以前从没听说过这个。
Mr. Owens has lived in the neighborhood since 1986. He thought he understood how the gangs worked. They were organized. They sold drugs.
欧文斯先生从1986年起就住在那个街区。他以为自己理解帮派是如何运作的。他们有组织。他们卖毒品。
You joined, got initiated. You became a bad guy. It was clear who was in them and who wasn't. The world Boogie was describing, where his son was kind of drafted into a gang war he didn't even really want to be a part of, that didn't make sense to Mr. Owens.
你加入，接受入会仪式。你成了坏人。谁在里面，谁不在里面，一清二楚。布吉描述的世界，他儿子被某种程度上强征入了他甚至不想参与的帮派战争中，这在欧文斯先生看来讲不通。
Towards the end of our conversation, we looked at a map of that new reality. We looked at the gang map Harper High School uses, where Terrance's initials, TG City, sit on a big rectangle southeast of the high school. Mr. Owen's had never seen anything like it.
在我们谈话快结束时，我们看了一张新现实的地图。我们看了哈珀高中使用的帮派地图，特伦斯的缩写“TG城”位于高中东南方的一大块矩形区域里。欧文斯先生从未见过这样的东西。
It upset him even more. TG City, he said. He'd always thought that was just a nice nickname the kids had given to the neighborhood, a way of remembering his son, not a gang.
这让他更加心烦。“TG城”，他说。他一直以为那只是孩子们给社区起的一个好听的昵称，一种纪念他儿子的方式，而不是帮派。
And that's what you just showed me. I'd never seen it. I never heard it before. I don't like that. I never heard it. I don't like it.
这就是你刚才向我展示的。我从未见过。以前从没听过。我不喜欢那个。我没听过。我不喜欢它。
I don't like it. I do not like that. When you showed me a map of the gang names and TG in that, oh, no. That's his initials. He don't fit in that. He don't fit in that.
我不喜欢它。我不喜欢那样。当你向我展示帮派名称和那上面的TG地图时，哦，不。那是他的名字缩写。他不属于那个。他不属于那个。
After a few minutes, we walked outside to take a break and get some fresh air. Mr. Owens stood on his porch. He told me a story about how the last time he'd seen Terrance was on his porch. It was morning. Mr. Owens was on his way to work. And he watched as his son walked around the corner to see Boogie and go get a haircut.
几分钟后，我们走到外面休息，呼吸新鲜空气。欧文斯先生站在他的门廊上。他给我讲了一个故事，说他最后一次见到特伦斯是在他的门廊上。那是早上。欧文斯先生去上班。他看着儿子转过街角去见布吉并去理发。
Today he stood there, staring at the house kitty corner to his. On one wall of it, there was spray paint that said TGC. Mr. Owen's stared, shaking his head. I don't like that, he said. I don't like that at all.
今天他站在那里，盯着他家对面的房子。墙上有一处喷漆写着“TGC”。欧文斯先生盯着，摇着头。我不喜欢那个，他说。我一点也不喜欢。
Ben Calhoun.
本·卡尔霍恩。
Act Three, How Kids Get Guns. Chicago's gun control laws are strict. There are no gun shops in the city, no shooting ranges. There's a ban on assault weapons and high capacity magazines.
第三幕，孩子们如何获得枪支。芝加哥的枪支管制法律很严格。城里没有枪支店，没有射击场。有对突击武器和大容量弹匣的禁令。
But somehow, of course, kids are being shot by other kids. Teenagers can't just walk into a store or a gun show and buy a gun. So how do they get them? The third of our Harper reporters, Linda Lutton, asked.
但不知何故，当然，孩子们正在被其他孩子枪击。青少年不能随便走进一家商店或枪展买枪。那么他们是如何得到的？我们的三名哈珀记者之一，琳达·拉顿，问了这个问题。
I talked to eight Harper students at school one day.
有一天我在学校和八名哈珀学生聊了聊。
Can you all come in a little tighter?
你们能靠得更近一点吗？
Most them are freshman, 15 years old. It was often hard at Harper to get kids to talk about how they felt about the violence in their neighborhood. But when it came to something concrete, like where a kid around here would get a gun, it was easy to get into a detailed conversation about dirty guns and clean guns and the prices of each. They said if it's a cheap gun on the street, you have to be careful. It might have a murder on it.
大多数是高一新生，15岁。在哈珀很难让孩子们谈论他们对社区暴力的感受。但当谈到一些具体的事情时，比如这附近的孩子会从哪儿弄到枪，很容易进入关于“脏枪”和“干净枪”以及各自价格的详细对话。他们说如果街上是一把便宜的枪，你必须小心。它上面可能背着一条命案。
It'll usually have a murder or something on it.
它通常会背着命案什么的。
And they know how clean guns, guns with no murders on them, end up on the street.
他们知道“干净的枪”（没有命案的枪）是如何流落街头的。
They got they gun cards. And then when they sell them, they just report them stolen-- like a month later, reported stolen.
他们有他们的持枪卡。然后当他们卖掉它们时，他们只是把它们报告为被盗——大概一个月后，报告被盗。
OK, what's the cheapest? Even if it's a dirty gun with a murder on it, what's the cheapest?
好的，最便宜的是多少？即使是背着命案的脏枪，最便宜的多少？
Like $100.
大概100美元。
It depends on what kind of gun it is.
这取决于它是什么样的枪。
$100. And what kind of gun would that be for $100?
100美元。那种100美元的枪是什么样的？
Because you gotta trick some people. They would be like, give me $100 for a .22 caliber. Boy, I don't even play with those. What, I'm going to give you $100? I'll give you $25 for it.
因为你得骗骗人。他们会说，给我100块钱买把.22口径的。老兄，我连那种都不玩。什么，我要给你100块钱？我给你25块钱得了。
The boys argue for a while over how much a .22 caliber handgun would be worth-- $25, $40, $150, or if it's worth anything at all since it's not a big gun. And who are they getting the guns from?
男孩们争论了一会儿.22口径的手枪值多少钱——25块、40块、150块，或者因为它不是什么大枪根本不值钱。他们从哪儿弄到枪？
As a kid, how do you know where to go to?
作为一个孩子，你怎么知道去哪儿找？
I go to one of the guys.
我找其中一个家伙。
That's what I was going to say, too-- one of the guys.
那也是我想说的——找其中一个家伙。
What does one of the guys mean? What does that mean?
“其中一个家伙”是什么意思？那是什么意思？
One of your friends.
你的朋友之一。
Well, like for some people, like if you're in a gang or something, you gonna automatically have that. So if you've got connections to a gang, then you gonna have it.
嗯，就像有些人，如果你加入了一个帮派什么的，你就会自动拥有。所以如果你和帮派有联系，你就会有。
So how do know who in the gang has the gun?
那你怎么知道帮派里谁有枪？
We know. We know.
我们知道。我们知道。
I've actually made phone calls. If wanted a gun--
我实际上打过电话。如果想要一把枪——
That's what I'm saying, too.
这也是我想说的。
I could make a phone call.
我可以打个电话。
Of course, this isn't the most satisfying answer to the question, where do you get your gun? To shrug and say, "from my friends," it doesn't explain how your friends get them. Guns arrive in the neighborhood through all the means you've probably heard of-- straw purchasers, gun show loopholes. The feds recently charged a college student with buying duffel bags full of guns at Indiana gun shows for sale on Chicago streets.
当然，这不是对“你从哪儿得到枪”这个问题最令人满意的回答。耸耸肩说“从我朋友那儿”，这并不能解释你的朋友们是怎么得到的。枪支通过你可能听说过的各种手段流入社区——“稻草买家”、枪展漏洞。联邦政府最近起诉了一名大学生在印第安纳州的枪展上购买装满帆布袋的枪支，准备在芝加哥街头出售。
A University of Chicago crime lab analysis has shown that the biggest proportion of police-recovered guns, around 40%, are purchased legally just outside Chicago, in the suburbs or Indiana. One of the police officers who works at Harper told me $40 or $50 would be a normal price around the neighborhood for a revolver. $100 will get you a semiautomatic.
芝加哥大学犯罪实验室的一项分析显示，警察回收的枪支中比例最大的部分（约40%）是在芝加哥郊区或印第安纳州合法购买的。一位在哈珀工作的警察告诉我，在附近，一把左轮手枪的正常价格是40或50美元。100美元能给你一把半自动手枪。
But talking to these kids, I realize they often can get a gun for nothing at all. They're free. This kid got two guns from his brother.
但和这些孩子谈话，我意识到他们经常可以免费得到枪。它们是免费的。这个孩子从他兄弟那儿得到了两把枪。
When my brother got it, of course he gonna give to me. Because my brother, he went to jail for a charge. He's still in there right now.
当我兄弟得到它时，当然他会给我。因为我兄弟，他因为一项指控进了监狱。他现在还在里面。
For a gun charge?
是因为持枪指控吗？
Yeah. My brother got several guns, though. But the one that he got caught with, they got it. But he got several of them. So I'm going to look at them for him while he in there.
是的。不过我兄弟有几把枪。但他被抓时拿的那把，他们收走了。但他还有好几把。所以在他进去的时候，我会帮他看着。
One kid says he was given a gun by fellow gang members who handed it to him, he says, for having certain rank in the gang. He was 14. Another boy who's backed away from his gang, he moved out of Englewood, says he could still get a gun if he needed it for something, as long as he promised to bring it back. Another boy says his mom has a gun, a legal gun. She keeps it in a box, he says.
一个孩子说他被同帮派成员给了一把枪，他说，因为他在帮派里有一定的地位。他那时14岁。另一个已经脱离帮派、搬出恩格尔伍德的男孩说，如果因为什么事需要枪，他仍然可以弄到一把，只要他承诺归还。另一个男孩说他妈妈有一把枪，一把合法的枪。他把枪放在盒子里，他说。
I was 12 when I got my first gun. I was 12. I found it. I saw it. I found it.
我12岁时有了第一把枪。我才12岁。我发现它。我看见它。我发现它。
He was near 67th Street, three blocks from Harper.
他当时在第67街附近，离哈珀三个街区。
Just in the middle of the day, you're going to your grandma's house. And you find a gun.
就在白天，你去你奶奶家。然后你发现了一把枪。
Yeah, it was 4 o'clock. And I walked through the alley because I had come up to my grandma's backyard. And something just told me, look down. It was five, six houses down from my grandma.
是的，那时是4点钟。我穿过小巷，因为我正要上我奶奶的后院。有什么东西告诉我要看下面。那是离我奶奶家五、六个房子的距离。
People stash guns outside. They don't want their guns in the house.
人们把枪藏在外面。他们不想让枪留在屋里。
All the kids agree, if a gun's in your house, the police can find it in a raid. So people stash them. This one was on the side of the garage.
所有的孩子都同意，如果枪在屋里，警察在突击搜查时就能找到它。所以人们把它们藏起来。这一把在车库旁边。
It was on the side of the garage like somebody tried to throw it in there while they was running. But they missed or something. It was just laying, not on the garage, on the garbage. You know, the garbages in the alley? It was just laying next to it. And I just picked it up, brung it home.
它在车库旁边，就像有人在奔跑时试图把它扔进去。但他们没扔准什么的。它就躺在那儿，不在车库上，在垃圾上。你知道，小巷里的垃圾箱吗？它就躺在旁边。我只是捡起来，带回家了。
The boy kept the gun for a while. Later, because he couldn't figure out how to get any bullets for it and because, he says, he had no use for it, he gave it to a friend. When I asked what type of gun it was, the boy said he was too little to know at the time.
那男孩把枪留了一阵子。后来，因为他不知道怎么给它弄子弹，而且他说他没用，就给了个朋友。当我问那是什么类型的枪时，那男孩说他当时太小了，不知道。
He only knew it was black. But now that he's older, 15, he does know. It was a .45.
他只知道它是黑色的。但现在他大了，15岁了，他知道了。那是一把.45口径的。
So where do you keep a gun, if not at home? I'm still not clear on that.
那么如果你不把枪放在家里，你把枪放在哪儿？我还没弄清楚。
Abandoned house, I'm going to say that.
废弃的房子，我想我会这么说。
A what?
什么？
Abandoned house.
废弃的房子。
What, like next door to you maybe or something?
什么，比如就在你隔壁或者什么的？
Well, not next door to you. I could be like a block or something. But it can't be that far.
嗯，不是就在你隔壁。可能隔一个街区什么的。但不能太远。
How do protect it, then? How do you know somebody's not going to get in there and get it?
那你怎么保护它呢？你怎么知道不会有人进去把它拿走？
Because you hide it.
因为你把它藏起来。
Well, maybe I live on your block, too, and I'm--
嗯，也许我也住在你那条街上，然后我——
Well, one of my guys, he had a banger. And he put it in an abandoned house. He put in the basement. And in the basement, they got a little vent. And just scooted it all the way back then just closed. And that's it.
嗯，我的人之一，他有一把枪。他把它放在了一间废弃的房子里。他把它放在地下室。地下室有个小通风口。他把它塞到最里面，然后关上。就这样。
So if he needs it, he's got it.
所以如果他需要，他就有了。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's not on him. It's not in his house.
但这并不在他身上。它不在他家里。
You're just close.
你只是离得很近。
As you'd expect, some guns are more popular than others.
正如你所预料的，有些枪比其他的更受欢迎。
Do young people want a certain type of gun?
年轻人想要特定类型的枪吗？
A .30.
.30口径的。
What kind?
什么样的？
A .30, with a long clip-- a clip like this out the gun.
一把.30口径的，带一个长弹匣——那种从枪里突出来的弹匣。
He's not talking about a specific gun but an accessory, a magazine that holds 30 rounds.
他说的不是特定的枪，而是一个配件，一个能装30发子弹的弹匣。
You like those? Why?
你喜欢那些？为什么？
They got the most shots. You can shoot forever. Let out 15. Run back to where you going. Somebody else come out and let out five more. There you go.
它们装的弹药最多。你可以开枪开个没完。打出15发。跑回到你要去的地方。另一个人出来再打出5发。这就对了。
A lot of these student say they know kids who are only alive because the shooters have such bad aim. That could be another reason why the long clips are popular with kids. It's a good accessory to have when you can't shoot.
很多这些学生说他们认识的孩子能活下来仅仅是因为枪手射击技术太差。这可能是长弹匣在孩子们中流行的另一个原因。当你不会射击时，它是一个很好的配件。
Linda Lutton. Coming up, you may remember that teenager who shot his own brother that we talked about in last week's program. We get back to him and what happened to him as the school year progressed. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
琳达·拉顿。接下来，你可能还记得我们在上周节目中谈到的那个枪击了自己亲兄弟的少年。我们将回到他身上，以及随着学年进行他身上发生了什么。稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. This is the second of two hours that we're broadcasting about Harper high school in the Englewood neighborhood of Chicago's South Side. Last year, the school had 29 shootings of current and recent students. We've had three reporters there for five months, starting at the beginning of the school year. We have arrived Act Four of our show. Act Four, Devonte, Part Two.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。这是我们正在播出的关于芝加哥南区恩格尔伍德社区哈珀高中的两个小时节目中的第二个小时。去年，学校发生了29起针对在校生和近期毕业生的枪击事件。我们有三名记者在那里待了五个月，从学年初开始。我们已经进入了节目的第四幕。第四幕，德冯特，第二部分。
One of our reporters, Alex Kotlowitz, spent his time at school in the social work office because that's a place that directly and intensively addresses the effects of the neighborhood's violence on specific students who go to the school. We heard one of the school's two social workers, Anita Stewart, earlier this hour.
我们的记者之一，亚历克斯·科特洛维茨，把他的时间花在学校的社会工作办公室，因为那里是一个直接且深入地解决邻里暴力对上学的具体学生造成影响的地方。我们在这个小时早些时候听到了学校两名社会工作者之一，安妮塔·斯图尔特的声音。
Crystal Smith is the other one. Crystal is relentlessly bright, positive, cheerful, peppy-- like, aggressively so. Here's how, early in the year, she says goodbye to a kid in her office who is leaving for class.
克里斯托·史密斯是另一位。克里斯托总是精力充沛、积极、开朗、活泼——像是非常有侵略性地开朗。这是年初时她如何向一个要离开她办公室去上课的孩子告别。
Hello. You are a person, OK. You are valuable. And you matter. Mwah, mwah, mwah. OK, go.
你好。你是一个人，好吗。你很有价值。你很重要。么，么，么。好了，去吧。
By late November this year, though, things have kind of changed. Alex explains how.
不过到了今年11月下旬，情况发生了变化。亚历克斯解释了原因。
It's the Tuesday before Thanksgiving break. And I run into Crystal Smith who's just coming in to work. She collapses into her chair.
那是感恩节假期的周二。我碰到了刚来上班的克里斯托·史密斯。她瘫倒在椅子上。
[DOOR SLAMS]
[关门声]
How you doing?
你怎么样？
I just got here. I've been battling my brain and just not feeling well since last night. But I'm here.
我刚到。从昨晚开始我就在跟自己的大脑斗争，感觉不太舒服。但我在这儿。
Since last night? What happened last night?
从昨晚开始？昨晚发生了什么？
Well, yesterday when I was at work, my whole face became numb. And my lips were tingling. My hand was numb, so I went--
嗯，昨天我在上班时，我整张脸都麻木了。我的嘴唇在刺痛。我的手麻木了，所以我去——
Crystal tells me that last night she went to the ER. She was worried she was having a stroke. But the doctor told her it was most likely symptoms of stress. But Crystal isn't just having a bad day. Work has been wearing her down. And others, it seem, are having a hard time, too.
克里斯托告诉我，昨晚她去了急诊室。她担心自己中风了。但医生告诉她这很可能是压力的症状。但克里斯托不仅仅是经历糟糕的一天。工作一直让她身心俱疲。看起来其他人也过得很艰难。
A week earlier, an administrator became so concerned about Crystal that she sent her, along with the school's other social worker and the school psychologist, to a counseling session just for the three of them. She wanted them to begin to process and move past all the crises and the shocks and the funerals they've been through the past year. Crystal and Anita, the other social worker, told me the session was helpful. But they also said it felt sort of pointless.
一周前，一位行政人员对克里斯托感到非常担忧，以至于把她和学校的另一位社会工作者、学校心理学家送到了一场仅限他们三个人的咨询会议。她希望他们开始处理并走出过去一年经历的所有危机、打击和葬礼。克里斯托和另一位社会工作者安妮塔告诉我，这次会议很有帮助。但她们也说觉得这有点毫无意义。
"It's not over," they said. Yeah, there haven't been any students killed this year. But the shooting hasn't stopped. I point out that that's how the kids must feel sometimes, and they agree. In the office, I tell Crystal that she looks tired.
“没结束，”她们说。是的，今年没有学生被杀。但枪击没停止。我指出这一定是孩子们有时感受到的，她们表示同意。在办公室里，我告诉克里斯托她看起来很累。
Yeah, I know. Next week, I'll try to be my, you know, ball of energy. I'm going to try. I don't know, maybe your book stressed me out.
是的，我知道。下周我会努力做回我的，你知道，活力四射的样子。我会努力的。我不知道，也许你的书让我感到压力了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Crystal's been working towards a second master's degree, and in one of her classes this year has been reading a book I wrote over 20 years ago called There Are No Children Here , where I follow two brothers living in the projects on Chicago's West Side. For a couple of years, I followed the boys as they grappled with violence, poverty, and the gangs. And Crystal wonders if reading it isn't adding to her stress.
克里斯托一直致力于攻读第二个硕士学位，今年在她的课上一直在读我20多年前写的一本书，叫《这里没有孩子》，记录了我追踪住在芝加哥西区贫民区的两个兄弟的过程。有几年，我追踪了这两个男孩，记录他们如何应对暴力、贫困和帮派。克里斯托想知道读这本书是不是增加了她的压力。
It was really interesting, though. To think that 20 years later, nothing has changed, that's the scarier part.
这真的很有趣。想到20年后，什么都没改变，那才是更可怕的部分。
You mean in the neighborhoods?
你是说在社区里？
Right. Right. That the same cycles are being repeated over again. OK, now what happened to the cousin, the one with the four kids?
对。对。同样的循环在反复上演。好了，那个有四个孩子的表弟怎么样了？
She's doing great. Her kids are going off to college. She lives up in Evanston, works in a bank.
她做得很好。她的孩子们都要上大学了。她住在埃文斯顿，在银行工作。
Really? She got out.
真的吗？她走出来了。
Yeah.
是的。
Really. I am so happy to hear that. I needed to hear that. I needed to know that. Wow. I need to see where education works. And I need to see where success happens.
真的。听到这个我太高兴了。我需要听到这个。我需要知道这个。哇。我需要看到教育发挥作用的地方。我需要看到成功发生的地方。
One of the things that's stressing Crystal out is her relationship with a junior named Devonte. Earlier in the year, Crystal begin meeting regularly with Devonte. I talked about him in last week's show. Last February, Devonte accidentally shot and killed his 14-year-old brother. Since then, his sister has stopped talking to him. And things have been strained with his mom.
让克里斯托感到压力的其中一件事是她与一个叫德冯特的高二学生的关系。今年早些时候，克里斯托开始定期与德冯特会面。我在上周的节目中谈到了他。去年二月，德冯特意外枪杀了他的14岁兄弟。从那以后，他妹妹就不跟他说话了。和他妈妈的关系也很紧张。
Before the accident, Devonte was kind of notorious as a problem kid at Harper. He would curse out the staff. And he hardly showed up for school. But since the beginning of this school year, Devonte's been turning it around.
事故发生前，德冯特在哈珀算是个有名的麻烦少年。他会辱骂教职员工。他几乎不去上学。但从本学年开始，德冯特一直在好转。
He comes to see Crystal sometimes two or three times a day. In spurts, he talks about his feelings, especially his guilt over his brother's death. He's pulled up his grades, getting Bs and Cs in almost all of his classes, the best grades he's ever had in high school.
他有时一天来看克里斯托两三次。他断断续续地谈论自己的感受，尤其是对兄弟去世的内疚。他提高了成绩，几乎所有课程都拿到了B和C，这是他高中以来最好的成绩。
So much of this success, I think, has to do with Crystal. For three months, she's let him know he doesn't need to go through this all alone. She encourages him to think about the future he wants for himself. Once when Devonte had stopped by, Crystal had pulled out photographs from a recent vacation she took with her husband in Jamaica.
我想，如此多的成功与克里斯托有关。三个月来，她让他知道他不必独自经历这一切。她鼓励他考虑自己想要的未来。有一次德冯特顺道来看她，克里斯托拿出了她最近和丈夫在牙买加度假的照片。
And so look, this is part of the resort that we were on. Every morning, you wake up and you see that.
所以看，这是我们待的度假村的一部分。每天早上醒来，你都会看到那个。
I like that. Almost look clean.
我喜欢那个。看起来很干净。
It is clean. And the water is so blue, you could see all the way down to the bottom.
它很干净。水很蓝，你可以一直看到底部。
Yes, you can
是的，你可以。
I don't need to go out there, though.
不过我不需要去那儿。
You do need to go out there. Look.
你确实需要去那儿。看。
The sun is small, isn't it?
太阳很小，不是吗？
I know. But I got a better picture of the sunset. I'll bring that later. And I'm going to give you one, because I want you to always make sure that you focused on getting to the sunset. OK? OK.
我知道。但我拍了一张更好的日落照片。我稍后会带过来。我会给你一张，因为我希望你一定要确保你专注于抵达日落。好吗？好吗？
So this conversation took place earlier in the fall. Now, today, the Tuesday before Thanksgiving, it seems like Devonte is drifting. Like Crystal and Anita, he just seems spent.
所以这次谈话发生在秋季早些时候。现在，今天，感恩节前的周二，德冯特看起来似乎在飘荡。像克里斯托和安妮塔一样，他看起来只是用尽了能量。
Crystal tells me Devonte's become agitated. He's announced that he's only going to come to school three days a week. I asked Devonte if he'd sit down with me and explain what's going on. I began by asking him about his relationship with Crystal.
克里斯托告诉我德冯特变得焦躁不安。他宣布他一周只来学校三天。我问德冯特是否愿意坐下来和我谈谈，解释一下发生了什么。我开始问他关于他和克里斯托的关系。
Now, I started getting along with Ms. Smith during sophomore year or something like that. And she started loving me.
嗯，我在高一那年还是什么的开始和史密斯女士相处得很好。她开始爱我了。
I think she's really fond of you. She worries about you.
我觉得她真的很喜欢你。她担心你。
Mmm-hmm, all the time. She worries about me all the time.
嗯哼，一直。她一直担心我。
Do you like it that she worries about you?
你喜欢她担心你吗？
Yeah. I like for a person to care for me and stuff.
是的。我喜欢有人关心我之类的。
I started to ask Devonte a bit about his brother and about the accident. But he told me that he didn't really want to talk about it-- which, you know, fair enough. He told me that he hates memories.
我开始问德冯特一些关于他兄弟和事故的事。但他告诉我他其实不想谈论——这，你知道，也很公平。他告诉我他讨厌记忆。
I don't like to think of stuff. I be wanting to give up on my life sometimes.
我不喜欢想事情。我有时想放弃我的生活。
Is that right, Devonte? Why?
是这样吗，德冯特？为什么？
I don't like my life no more. I hate myself.
我不再喜欢我的生活了。我恨我自己。
Why do you hate yourself?
为什么你恨你自己？
I don't know.
我不知道。
You hate what happened, right? But you don't hate yourself?
你恨发生的事，对吧？但你不恨你自己？
Peoples be looking at me stupid, all the--
人们看我的眼神很愚蠢，所有的——
Do people say things to you, Devonte?
人们会对你说什么吗，德冯特？
Uh-uh.
唔唔。
So you just think people are looking at you differently?
所以你只是觉得人们看你的方式不一样了？
I see people looking at me other different type of ways.
我看到人们用不同的方式看我。
Do you think Ms. Smith does?
你觉得史密斯女士是吗？
No. And I'm talking about people in my family. I feel that they don't care about me no more. Like if I leave this world, they don't care.
不。我是在说我家人。我觉得他们不再关心我了。就像如果我离开这个世界，他们也不在乎。
You think they're angry with you.
你觉得他们对你很生气。
I  heard my sister say, my little brother go, everybody go, and don't never come back. And I don't want to flip out on nobody. I've been thinking about me just giving up.
我听到我妹妹说，我弟弟走了，每个人都走了，再也不回来了。我不想对任何人发火。我一直在想放弃。
That conversation happened two days before the Thanksgiving break. When I next meet up with Crystal a few weeks later, she tells me that Devonte has stopped coming to school, that she hasn't heard from him. What's worse, though, is that she says she's heard from some of the school staff that he's been picked up by the police on a gun possession charge. Crystal calls Devonte's mom to find out what's going on.
那次谈话发生在感恩节假期前两天。几周后我再次见到克里斯托时，她告诉我德冯特不再来学校了，她一直没他的消息。更糟糕的是，她说她听学校教职员工说他因为持枪指控被警察抓了。克里斯托给德冯特的妈妈打电话弄清楚发生了什么。
Hello, can I please speak with Mrs. Grant? Hey, it's Crystal Winfield Smith. How are you?
你好，能和格兰特夫人通话吗？嘿，我是克里斯托·温菲尔德·史密斯。你好吗？
Good, good, good. The police are there looking for Devonte? What?
好，好，好。警察在那儿找德冯特？什么？
Devonte's mom confirms that, yes, Devonte had been picked up on a gun charge, and that earlier in the week went to court for a preliminary hearing. She says that once Devonte heard that he could get locked up for 19 months, he got scared and took off. He literally ran out of the courthouse. He's now on the run. She says she's not sure where he's staying now.
德冯特的妈妈证实，是的，德冯特因为持枪指控被抓，周初去法院参加了初步听证会。她说一旦德冯特听到他可能会被关19个月，他就害怕并逃跑了。他从法院跑了出来。他现在正在逃亡。她说她不确定他现在待在哪儿。
Crystal knows that Devonte will just get more caught up in the streets, fending for himself, and that at some point the police will get him. And when they do, he's facing serious charges-- the gun charge itself, violation of probation, which he was on for the accidental shooting, maybe running from the court.
克里斯托知道德冯特只会更多地卷入街头生活，独自挣扎，而且在某个时候警察会抓住他。当他们抓到他时，他面临严重指控——持枪指控本身，违反假释规定（因为那起意外枪击案他还在假释中），也许还有从法院逃跑。
It makes me feel like I lost him. And how could I lose him when I'm reaching my hand out? Grab back.
这让我觉得我失去他了。我向他伸出了手，怎么还能失去他？抓回来啊。
A few days later, Crystal calls Devonte. She tells him not to say where he is, so she won't have to lie for him. She then runs through what, for them, has by now become a familiar exercise.
几天后，克里斯托给德冯特打电话。她告诉他别说他在哪儿，这样她就不必为他撒谎了。然后她复习了对他们来说已经成为熟悉练习的内容。
When you look in the mirror, what do you see? Crystal asks. The good Devonte, he replies. Then Crystal remind him, don't forget he's in there.
当你照镜子时，你看到了什么？克里斯托问。好德冯特，他回答。然后克里斯托提醒他，别忘了他在那儿。
And so it was very hard for me. And I said, OK, son. I love you. And take care of yourself.
所以这对我来说非常艰难。我说，好的，孩子。我爱你。照顾好你自己。
And he said, I love you, too, ma. And I hung up. That's that.
他说，我也爱你，妈。然后我就挂了。就是这样。
Alex Kotlowitz.
亚历克斯·科特洛维茨。
Act Five, Reverse Turnaround Backflip. The time of year that we're in right now is hard for Principal Sanders because it's budget time, planning next year's budget. Harper is actually in a good situation this year with money. But as Ben Calhoun explains, that's about to change.
第五幕，反向翻转。我们现在所处的这一年时间对桑德斯校长来说很难，因为是预算时间，计划明年的预算。哈珀今年的资金情况其实不错。但正如本·卡尔霍恩所解释的，情况即将改变。
Harper's in a unique spot at the moment because it's what the Chicago school system calls a turnaround school. A few years ago, the system said Harper need an overhaul. So they turned over most of the staff, brought in new people, and infused the school with money, a lot of money.
哈珀目前处于一个独特的位置，因为它是芝加哥学校系统所说的“转折学校”。几年前，系统说哈珀需要大修。所以他们撤换了大部分教职员工，引入了新人，并向学校注入了资金，大量的资金。
Just to give you an idea, Harper's total budget this year is $8.9 million. $1.6 million of that is turnaround money. Last year, the turnaround money was even bigger, almost $2 million.
给你一个概念，哈珀今年的总预算是890万美元。其中的160万美元是转折资金。去年，转折资金更大，将近200万美元。
One former district official involved in Harper's turnaround told me that Secretary of Education Arne Duncan, who used to run Chicago's schools, he said to his former colleagues, with these new turnaround initiatives, like the one at Harper, he wanted to, quote, "take the issue of money off the table," in other words, give them whatever they need. So the plan was pretty much boost the school with a lot of federal, state, and city money, then as the changes took hold, slowly ramp down the money.
一位参与哈珀转折的前区官员告诉我，教育部长阿恩·邓肯（曾经运营芝加哥学校）对他的前同事说，有了这些新的转折倡议，像哈珀这样的，他想引用，“把资金问题从桌面上拿掉”，换句话说，给他们任何他们需要的。所以计划基本上是用大量的联邦、州和市资金提振学校，然后随着变化扎根，慢慢减少资金。
And then five years later, the funding would go back to normal. That's next year. Next year is when the money goes away.
然后五年后，资金将恢复正常。那是明年。明年资金就会消失。
In the fall, I sat down with Principal Sanders and the school's operations manager to talk about all this. They told me the money has done so much. There's a new culinary learning room, new computer equipment, small stuff like a new ID machine.
秋天，我和桑德斯校长及学校的运营经理坐下来谈论这一切。他们告诉我这笔钱做了很多事。有一个新的烹饪学习室，新的电脑设备，像新的ID机器这样的小东西。
Principal Sanders talks about the first year of turnaround like it was amazing. There were four assistant principals, reduced class sizes. There was the kind of support staff-- social workers and counselors-- in numbers that other schools only dream of.
桑德斯校长谈起转折的第一年就像那是神奇的一样。有四位助理校长，减小了班级规模。社会工作者和辅导员等支持人员的数量是其他学校只能梦想的。
The operations manager told me he's been a Chicago Public Schools money guy for 15 years. He's been at more than 10 other high schools. He told me he's seen programs like the turnaround program before. It was called other things-- intervention, reconstitution but he says bluntly that Harper is the first time he's seen it work, partly because there's just been more money this time.
运营经理告诉我他当芝加哥公立学校的资金主管15年了。他待过10多所其他高中。他断言这是他第一次看到它起作用，部分原因只是这次钱更多了。
So next year, though, Harper will lose the last $1.6 million of turnaround money, about 18% of its budget. And the biggest effect of that will be layoffs.
所以明年，哈珀将失去最后160万美元的转折资金，约占预算的18%。而最大的影响将是裁员。
What's up, [INAUDIBLE]?
怎么了，[听不清]？
HEY.
嘿。
How you feeling?
你感觉如何？
Good.
好。
Hey, Miss Carter. Is that a pass in your hand? I'm so proud of you, Miss Carter.
嘿，卡特小姐。你手里是通行证吗？我为你感到自豪，卡特小姐。
What effect will layoffs have on Harper? I spend a couple mornings with a staff member named Marcel Smith. Marcel works on a program that tries to rescue kids who are failing out. Harper has a lot of initiatives like that. There's mentoring programs and enrichment programs, all boosted by turnaround.
裁员会对哈珀产生什么影响？我花了好几个早晨和一名叫马塞尔·史密斯的员工在一起。马塞尔负责一个试图拯救那些正在失败的学生的项目。哈珀有很多这样的倡议。有导师项目和充实项目，都得到了转折资金的提振。
So on paper, that's what Marcel does. But if you walk around with him, you see what Sanders sees, all the little things that would never be considered part of his job. The day I was with him, in the morning, Marcel came across a young man standing in the hallway.
所以书面上，这就是马塞尔做的事。但如果你和他一起走动，你就会看到桑德斯看到的那些小事，永远不会被认为是他工作的一部分。我跟着他的那天，早上，马塞尔碰到一个年轻人站在走廊上。
What's going on, son? How you feeling?
怎么了，孩子？感觉如何？
The kid was keeping a straight face. But he was clearly upset. It turned out he'd been asked to leave his class. As Marcel turned to deal with him, he asked me to turn off the recorder, so I did.
那孩子面无表情。但他显然很难过。结果是他被要求离开教室。当马塞尔转身处理他时，他让我关掉录音机，我就关了。
They talked for a minute. Marcel took the kid to his office, sat him down, told him to wait. And we walked away. He didn't want to use the student's name. But he explained what was going on.
他们谈了一分钟。马塞尔把那孩子带到他办公室，让他坐下，告诉他等在那儿。我们走开了。他不想用那个学生的名字。但他解释了发生了什么。
Apparently, the students were given an incentive for being on time. And it was food.
显然，学生们因为准时而得到奖励。是食物。
Cookies. It was cookies. And this student, along with everyone who'd gotten to class on time that day, was allowed to go up and take a cookie. But this particular student was dealing with a difficult and maybe dangerous situation at his house. So he hadn't gone home the night before. And because of that, he hadn't eaten.
曲奇饼。是曲奇饼。这个学生，和那天所有准时进教室的人一样，被允许走过去拿一块曲奇。但这个特定的学生家里正在处理一个困难且可能危险的情况。所以他前一天晚上没回家。正因为如此，他没吃东西。
So when he went up to take his cookie, he took two. The teacher told them to put one back. Not wanting to reveal his situation to the rest of the class, he didn't say anything. He just refused.
所以当他走过去拿曲奇时，他拿了两块。老师让他们放回一块。不想向班上其他人透露他的情况，他什么都没说。他只是拒绝了。
He told Marcel he was just so hungry. That's why he'd been kicked out. Marcel had a box of cereal in his office. And I walked with him as he zipped down to the cafeteria. They were out of regular milk.
他告诉马塞尔他只是太饿了。这就是他被赶出来的原因。马塞尔办公室里有一盒麦片。我陪着他飞快跑到自助餐厅。常规牛奶没了。
Ladies? Ladies, how y'all doing? Can I get two chocolate milks, please? Thank you.
女士们？女士们，你们好吗？请给我两瓶巧克力牛奶，好吗？谢谢。
Back in Marcel's office, the student sat quietly, staring down, and ate a plastic bowl filled with Honey Nut Cheerios and chocolate milk. Then he got up, politely washed the bowl and spoon, said thank you to Marcel, and the two went back to his classroom. You see situations like this all the time at Harper, situations that could so easily unravel.
回到马塞尔的办公室，那学生安静地坐着，盯着看，吃了一碗塑料碗装的蜂蜜坚果脆片和巧克力牛奶。然后他站起来，礼貌地洗了碗和勺子，对马塞尔说了谢谢，两人一起回到教室。你在哈珀一直能看到这种情况，那些很容易就会失控的情况。
And without thinking anything of it, they get addressed because someone is there and makes the effort to figure out what's going on. It's stuff that'll never show up in a school budget. But it can be the difference between a kid going back to class or getting suspended.
而且不用考虑任何事，它们就能得到解决，因为有人在那里并努力弄清楚发生了什么。这是永远不会出现在学校预算中的东西。但这可能是学生回教室或被停学的区别。
Kids, you know, you can't tell kids when not to have a good day. Like, you can't have a good day on Tuesdays and Thursdays, because I'm not going to be there. You can only have bad days on Monday, Wednesdays, and Fridays.
孩子们，你知道，你不能告诉孩子什么时候不能有美好的一天。就像，你周二和周四不能有美好的一天，因为我不会在那里。你只能在周一、周三和周五有糟糕的一天。
This is exactly what Principle Sanders is worried about next year when the turnaround money goes away, the people she'll have to give up. Marcel's position is funded through next year. But he's exactly the kind of person who there won't be money for. Assistant Principal Chad Adams, the school psychologist, numerous teaching positions-- not currently funded for next year. The social workers who you've heard working with Thomas and Devonte-- there's Crystal, and there's Anita-- next year, Anita will go away. And Crystal will only be part time.
这正是桑德斯校长担心的明年转折资金消失后的情况，她不得不放弃的人们。马塞尔的职位资金只维持到明年。但他正是那种明年没钱聘用的人。副校长查德·亚当斯、学校心理学家、大量的教职岗位——目前没有明年的资金。那些你听到在和托马斯和德冯特一起工作的社会工作者——有克里斯托，还有安妮塔——明年，安妮塔将离职。而克里斯托只能兼职。
Altogether, Harper expects to lose at least a dozen people, about a tenth of the current staff. Two of the security staff who have seen Harper go through overhauls in the past say it always changes when the money is added. But then everything goes backwards once it's lost. There's more fights. The violence gets worse.
总共，哈珀预计将失去至少十几个人，约占现有教职员工的十分之一。两个曾经见证哈珀在过去经历过大修的安保人员说，当钱增加时它总是会改变。但一旦钱没了，一切都会倒退。打架更多了。暴力更严重了。
You know, I mean, there's not much we can do. $1.6 million is a lot of money to lose. Every day, I wish I could win the lottery and just pay people out of my pocket.
你知道，我的意思是，我们能做的很少。160万美元是一大笔钱。每天，我希望我能中彩票，然后从我口袋里付钱给人们。
When Sanders first said that, it was a joke, not much to it. Except for what Ms. Sanders said then. She told me she does find herself thinking about what she would do if she won the lottery. And a lot of that money, she'd put it into the school.
当桑德斯第一次说那个时，那是句玩笑话，没什么大不了的。除了桑德斯女士后来说的。她告诉我她确实发现自己会思考如果她中彩票会做什么。而那笔钱的一大部分，她会投入到学校。
I would hook Harper up. And everybody would be sitting back like, dang.
我会把哈珀装扮起来。大家都会坐着看，说“该死”。
And then she laid out her plan.
然后她列出了她的计划。
And I would say, yeah, I mean, they would have the state of the art labs. Every student would have access to a computer. Any of the capital resources, human resources, that we needed, they would have.
我会说，是的，我的意思是，他们会有最先进的实验室。每个学生都能使用电脑。任何我们需要资本资源、人力资源，他们都会有。
Sanders kept going like this for 4 minutes and 38 seconds. With her imaginary millions, she bought big things, like vacant land near the school. She rehabbed houses where students who are homeless would have a place to stay. She created transportation programs to get kids to and from school safely.
桑德斯就这样持续说了4分38秒。用她想象中的数百万美元，她买了大事，比如学校附近的闲置土地。她翻新了无家可归的学生有地方住的房子。她创造了交通项目，让孩子们安全往返学校。
She did little things. She took a kid who came to school in a hoodie in the middle of winter, and she bought him a coat. She bought detergent for kids who didn't have soap to wash their uniforms. She spent, and she spent. 10 years, she said. She'd structure it out so that the money would be spread out over 10 years.
她做了小事。她带了一个在冬日里穿着连帽衫来学校的孩子，她给他买了外套。她给那些没肥皂洗制服的孩子买了洗涤剂。她花呀花呀。10年，她说。她会把它结构化，让钱分摊到10年里。
So things like that, if I was to win money. It's such a need here. It's just such a need here.
所以像那样的事，如果我有钱的话。这里真的太需要了。这里真的太需要了。
How often do you find yourself budgeting out that imaginary money, that if you had it?
你多久会发现自己在预算那笔想象中的钱，如果你有的话？
I do it a lot. [LAUGHS] I do it because every time, it's like a different situation. And I just sit back and say what if? God, what if?
我经常这样。[笑声] 我这样做是因为每次，这就像是一个不同的情况。我只是坐下来问如果呢？天呐，如果呢？
Ben Calhoun.
本·卡尔霍恩。
Act Six, We Are Harper High School.
第六幕，我们是哈珀高中。
[SCHOOL BELL RINGING]
[学校铃声]
All right, be safe.
好的，注意安全。
Last day of the semester. This is the day that we ended our reporting at Harper. Marcel Smith, saying goodbye to kids who are on their way home.
学期的最后一天。这是我们结束在哈珀报道的日子。马塞尔·史密斯在跟回家的孩子们告别。
I saw that somebody tweeted after our first episode about Harper High School was broadcast. Somebody said that we found the most violent school in America or in Chicago or something. And I just want to say, that is not true.
我看到有人在我们关于哈珀高中的第一集播出后发了推特。有人说我们发现了美国或芝加哥最暴力的学校什么的。我只想说，那不是真的。
Nobody keeps statistics like that. We just found a high school-- a high school that's seen a lot of shootings. And there are others.
没人保留那样的统计数据。我们只是发现了一所高中——一所看到很多枪击事件的高中。还有其他的。
Hi, I'm Liz Dozier, the Principle of Finger High School on the far South Side of Chicago. We've lost nine students to violence in the last little over three years.
你好，我是利兹·多齐尔，芝加哥远南区的芬格尔高中校长。过去三年多一点，我们因暴力失去了九名学生。
I am Shontae Higgenbottom. And I'm the new principal here at King College Prep High School here in Chicago. And this year, I've had two students who were shot during our Christmas break. And then we had the last case with Hadiya Pendleton. And she died.
我是肖恩泰·希根波顿。我是芝加哥国王学院预科高中的新任校长。今年，我有两名学生在圣诞假期期间被枪击。然后我们有了哈迪亚·彭德尔顿的最后一个案例。她去世了。
My name is John Lynch. I'm the Principle of Castlemont High School in Oakland, California. So I've been at Castlemont High School for the past two and a half years. And in the time that I've been here, six students have been shot. And two of those students who were shot were actually killed.
我叫约翰·林奇。我是加利福尼亚州奥克兰卡斯尔蒙特高中的校长。我在卡斯尔蒙特高中待了两年半了。在我待在这里的这段时间里，六名学生被枪击了。其中两名被枪击的学生确实去世了。
I am Bertie Simmons. And I am the Principal of Furr High School. And it's located on the Far East Side of Houston, Texas. In the last two years, I could name five students that were shot and killed.
我是伯蒂·西蒙斯。我是弗尔高中的校长。它位于德克萨斯州休斯顿的远东区。在过去两年里，我能点出五名被枪杀的学生。
My name is Rahel Wondwossen. And I am the Principle of Cohen College Prep High School. We are located in Central City, New Orleans. At Cohen College Prep High School last year, we had two students who were shot. Both, thankfully, survived. And in the city of New Orleans, we had more than 10 students who were shot and killed.
我叫拉赫尔·沃多森。我是科恩学院预科高中的校长。我们位于新奥尔良中心城。去年在科恩学院预科高中，我们有两名学生被枪击了。庆幸的是，两人都活了下来。在新奥尔良市，我们有超过10名学生被枪杀。
My name is LaQuanda Jackson. I'm the Principle of Simon Gratz Mastery Charter High School in Philadelphia. This year, we have lost one student to gun violence. Last year, we lost two students to gun violence. And the year before, there were six.
我叫拉昆达·杰克逊。我是费城西蒙·格拉茨硕士特许高中的校长。今年，我们失去了一名因枪支暴力的学生。去年，我们失去两名学生因枪支暴力。前一年，有六名。
My name is Alberto Carvalho. I am the Superintendent of Miami-Dade County Public Schools right here in Florida. Over the past four and a half years, I have buried or attended viewings for 44 children who have died violent deaths right here in our community.
我叫阿尔贝托·卡瓦略。我是佛罗里达州迈阿密戴德县公立学校的学监。在过去四年半里，我埋葬了或参加了44名在本社区因暴力死亡的儿童的告别仪式。
Well, our program was produced today by our senior producer Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, John Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Production help from Phia Bennin. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant.
好了，我们节目今天由我们的资深制作人朱莉·斯奈德制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·凯尼格、米基·米克、约翰·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。菲亚·本宁提供制作帮助。赛斯·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康登是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。
Music help today from Damien Grey, from Rob Geddis. Original musical scoring for today's program by Rob under the name The Latebloomer. Other Latebloomer music is on SoundCloud.
音乐帮助来自达米安·格雷，罗伯·格迪斯。今天节目的原创音乐配乐由罗伯以“迟开者”的名字创作。其他迟开者音乐在SoundCloud上。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Tony Malatia, who went on one of those Prarie Home Companion vacations.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监管由我们的老板，托尼·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他去参加了那些“草原家园伴侣”假期。
He showed me pictures. They're incredible. Every morning, Garrison Keillor personally wakes you at your bed in a white suit.
他给我看了照片。令人难以置信。每天早上，加里森·凯勒会亲自穿白西装在床边叫醒你。
This is part of the resort that we were on. Every morning, you wake up and you see that.
这是我们待的度假村的一部分。每天早上，你醒来就会看到那个。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI-- Public Radio International.
PRI——国际公共广播电台。